alright let's see who else is on the
phones because there are a lot of people
here waiting let's go to our caller from
the 8th 1/8 area code caller from 8 1 8
what's on your mind
hey David so I think it's fair to say
that no matter what happens with the Bob
ball investigation
Trump's approval probably won't dip
below like 25 or 30 percent like no
matter what happens a maybe a quarter so
the country will just stick with them to
the bitter end I think so so what I'd
like to ask ya what I'd like to ask is
even when Trump is gone what happens to
these people because like I find it
funny the look at Trump supporters
online but I also find it kind of
starving to see kind of like how easily
exported there and how willing they are
to be exploited by somebody as stupid as
Trump so yeah like have we basically
entered an idiocracy age in American
politics like is there going to be a
Trump 2.0 well well there's a couple
different ways this could go it's an
interesting question what happens to the
trumpets after Trump what what is a post
Trump world like four trumpets do they
just see it as the golden era as so many
ideological conservatives now see the
1950s that that's what we would like to
get back to you I don't know I think
that there will be significant I
actually worry that post Trump you might
see significantly increased levels of
violence from trumpets that's that's one
question even if he has a successful
presidency to their standards yeah goes
out with two full terms yeah I think
that after he's gone if things don't go
the way that they expect then or believe
that they should go that they might they
might become significantly inflamed I
think that the broader question is does
Trump trigger for lack of a better term
Trump 2.0 trump 3.0 does Trump
legitimize the idea of sort of a
clueless buffoon being a president and
that is that that's the biggest concern
for me because I think the answer is yes
I think the answer is yes because even
with only 25% you can basically with
with 50% voter turnout you can win an
election with I mean at certainly with
26% approval even less if you get the
votes in the right States because of the
electoral
vote system so that's really the concern
for me the idea that now we are going to
get Trump 2.0 and 3.0 and that it'll be
an absolute mess you can get president
ted nugent or president kid rock maybe
yeah and we're kind of joking but not
really so yeah i don't know what's going
to happen but I'm not super optimistic
yeah I mean it really worries me to see
people like what's his name Greg Ginn
forte and I believe Montana which I
after like assaulting a reporter
yep buddy and yeah in addition to just a
dumbass rhetoric it seems like there's a
lot of people who revel in the violent
rhetoric as well and sometimes actions
these people no doubt no doubt and of
course you will always hear from them
listen trump has never actually
advocated violence which of course isn't
true he actually literally advocated
violence and said he would pay the legal
fees of people who punch protestors at
events but putting that aside the
rhetoric is also part of it and we know
that it has catalyzed all sorts of
extremist groups with a lot of violence
okay thank you very much for the call
appreciate it great to hear from you